recent polls now showing california
governor gavin newsom
is in the danger zone that he can in
fact be recalled
new poll out of berkeley finds that
likely recall voters are nearly split
even on whether to recall newsome but
who is the best candidate then to
replace him so far
looks like voters are turning towards
our friend larry elder who is now
leading the recall challenger by a
whopping 10 points
he's here with reaction he's now
officially a gubernatorial candidate
actually on the ballot they tried to
keep him off for some reason
larry elder and his number one fan and
supporter leo 2.0 terrell
i always thought from the beginning that
question one
was going to be the hard question will
do people vote to recall
gavin newsom you need 50 percent plus
one
larry this look now looks like a
possibility
well that's right it's in the margin of
error and uh that's a dramatic increase
from just a couple weeks ago look people
have had it
they've had it with these ridiculous
mandates that you've been talking about
and recently the governor gavin newsom
has said if you're a state worker and
you haven't been vaccinated you're going
to be tested once a week
and while at work you're going to wear a
mask now i thought the whole point
behind being vaccinated is that you're
protected against people
who haven't been vaccinated and now
you're telling people who haven't been
vaccinated who've assumed the risk
they're going to wear masks to protect
other unvaccinated people
who've also assumed the risk it doesn't
make any sense
and that's why 2.2 million californians
sign this petition about a quarter of
them
are democrats and independents who voted
for this guy just two years earlier
we haven't talked about the crime and
the rising cost of living
and the outrageous homelessness while
this guy has his own kids
enjoying in school private education and
while he exempted himself from the very
mandates he pushed down the throats of
the
of californians that's why i'm urging
people to go to elect elder.com
throw something in the tip jar because i
have expenditure limitations he can
raise and spend as much money as he
wants
and most people believe he's going to
spend at least 50 million dollars to try
to defeat me because he's scared to
death
leo i mean this guy goes to restaurants
when he tells everyone else not to his
kids
have in-person learning in a private
school
draconian shutdowns you know the highest
taxes in the country
you know can this be real yeah it is
really i'll tell you why first of all
larry has the ability to resonate with
the everyday people
gavin newsom administration is a train
wreck
he's an elitist last week he lied to the
people in california and said
crime was on the decline i don't think
barbara boxer and people who live in
california
believe that crime is on the decline
then he had the
audacity to compare people who may have
a medical reason
not to get vaccinated to drunk driving
that's how
the analogy doesn't make sense he's an
elitist and as larry mentioned his son
doesn't follow the rules of wearing a
mask he lied on television again
about his kids going to uh heavy online
training they were in
private school the guys and leaders his
administration the train wreck
and larry resonate with the everyday
voter
well hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else